1968 sizzling faye allen became
britain's first ever black policewoman
despite enduring years of racist abuse
from inside and
outside of the force she paved the way
for other black women to join the met
police
as part of our coverage of black history
month ms allen has spoken to sky news
about her historical achievement
as well as the race inequalities which
still exist in britain
today sky's noel phillips has this
special report
london is the place for me
london this lovely city
throughout the 1950s and 60s jamaicans
were encouraged by the british
government
to leave their homes and come to the uk
that
open invitation led to one woman
changing the course of history
this is me at peel
house with minister metropolitan police
training school at the time
i didn't set out to make history i
just wanted a change of
direction and this was on the 19th of
april
1968. it's a long long journey but
i'll do it all over again
completing her training in the
metropolitan police britain's first
colored policewoman
mrs cicilyn faye allen from jamaica the
journey began 52 years ago
this was sicily faye allen aged 29. as a
new recruit she's taking part in a mock
exercise at the metropolitan police
training school in london
at the time she became the first black
policewoman in britain
and it was whilst working as a nurse in
south london when she decided to join
the force
i was on my lunch break
and going through the papers i saw
this advert advertising they were
recruiting
police officers yeah so i looked at it
and i thought
why not after i finished work
and i went home you know that's what i
did
i filled this thing out then i posted it
off
and thought nothing of it so
within a fortnight
i got a reply from the metropolitan
police
and they posted some forms
for me to fill out and return
so i did this and
at the end i
i penned at the bottom of it
that i was a black woman
because i didn't want if
i had succeeded and when they see me
they would think um i didn't know she
was black
or something like that you know so i
specifically
wrote there as i was black but there
were friends who were telling you that
they wouldn't accept a black woman in
the police
when i went back to work
and my friend i was saying to her
you know i i think i'm going to join the
police force
and she said don't be so silly they're
not accepting black people
and then i said well i've got news for
you
i have been accepted but you couldn't
believe it cicelyn managed to defy the
odds to pursue her dream
but it is worth remembering what britain
looked like at the time
in the same year she made history
conservative mp enoch powell
delivered his controversial rivers of
blood speech
in this country in 15 or 20 years time
the black man will have the whip hand
over the white man
well i can already hear
the chorus of execration
he was strongly critical of commonwealth
immigrants in the uk
you were facing a lot of prejudice and
discrimination
from outside the force but also inside
you encountered a few problems
i mean they didn't want to have like
police officers
or whatever you know and then they
thought well
they have to make it known again some of
them
were livid i mean i got um
quite a lot of you know letters
because it came through scotland and
um there were some very
nice letters but there were some
horrible ones i was told i've never seen
them
because they they didn't give them to me
they thought
if i saw these letters
you know i would i wouldn't
go on with the trouble not i'll leave
as the only woman of colour at the time
it was a lonely experience
cicelyn spent four years with the met
before leaving in 1972
she returned to jamaica with her family
where she also became a police officer
i think you still have a long way to go
you know but at the end of the day i was
glad that i was able to
inspire so many people
you know take up the challenge you know
and they're all doing a good job
hawaii's from wind russia immigrant to
britain's first ever black police woman
is a legacy which stretches far beyond
these shores
there isn't a single woman who can't now
dream the dream
in britain sicily's contribution still
resonates today
i'd like to say a massive thank you to
cicelyn because she has paved the way
she was the person who came in
she was that black female who came in
and clearly made some
incredible sacrifices and contributions
to policing
and it's part of the reason why i'm here
today
commander alison hyderi is the highest
ranking a black woman
in the country she says that she's an
example that policing
is ready for a change my belief is that
we have come an awfully long way even if
you look in the last five
10 15 20 years there's been so much
going on around
more black and minority ethnic
staff and officers joining the met
joining policing in general
however i do think that we have a way to
go
looking back at her life cicelyn tells
me she carried a heavy weight
of expectations some of which she was
able to fulfill
her dream was to climb the ranks and
become an inspector
but nonetheless she has no regrets would
you do it all again
if and when i could do it i would do it
all over again
you know i have to recommend it any day
to anybody if you can help somebody
along the way
that's a lot of satisfaction this is a
woman whose story has until now
largely been overlooked in history
cicelyn faye allen defied the odds to
change
the face of british policing noel
phillips
sky news in saint anne's jamaica